jerry is on the line in New York hi
Jerry welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave I would I would ask how you're
doing but I think I know the answers to
that all right some things are
predictably so I'll get straight to the
point I'm 23 I just got married three
months ago congratulations thank you
thank you I have a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in savings right now in
mutual funds we have me and my wife
together we have household income of
around 200 to 250 and we have 98
thousand dollars in student loan debt
under the name of my wife I'm wondering
if I should pay that down immediately if
I should refinance or if I should
continue investing in the mutual funds
and hopefully make the spread on the
interest rate and whatever I'm getting
on the mutual funds okay cool
you guys are making a lot of money for
23 years old what do y'all do for a
living
we're both in finance well done very
well done yeah so you're academically
trained in the world of finance I'm not
my wife is I studied computer science
and economics but more or less yes all
right when you're analyzing an
investment and you're comparing a risky
investment with a non risk investment do
you remember the statistical measure of
risk being called a beta does that sound
familiar
yeah yes so the higher the peaks and
valleys on the graph the higher the beta
means higher risk it's volatile correct
correct okay to compare debt with a
mutual fund and the returns on a mutual
fund are not guaranteed the debt is
guaranteed to drain the marrow out of
your bones over time and to compare
those two things apples to apples and
not adjust for risk using the beta would
be in it would be a naive financial
formula however no
one teaches this in finance by the way
I'm the only ones ever brought this up
bottom line is is that you are taking on
risk that is that when you
mathematically adjust for the risk
because you're carrying them the debt
the data equals risk and when you
mathematically adjust for the risk the
spread you're making on it and the
mutual funds goes away an example of why
this why you wouldn't do this is like
this sounds like this you've got a
hundred thousand dollars in a mutual
fund or you've got a hundred thousand
dollars in a student loan what if we
said you can borrow ten million dollars
or more on mutual on the exact same
student loans and you have to put it all
in mutual funds all of a sudden when I
say that something happened not in your
head but right below your ribcage above
the top of your stomach and you went
gulp right yeah yeah yeah and so that
that's where you measure risk is right
around the area of your heart your heart
frisk measures your head does math and
so my point is it's not a big deal
because you guys make a lot of money
you're two very smart young people
you're probably not gonna go bankrupt
over this you're not going to be you're
not gonna have your financial growth
stunted over this and so more than
anything it's a it's a almost a
mathematical philosophical discussion
here that we're having because it's not
gonna kill you but the way I answer
questions on this show knowing what I
know from an academic viewpoint a
spiritual viewpoint a relational
viewpoint a behavior standpoint in a
wealth building viewpoint from 30 years
of doing this what would I do if I woke
up in your shoes I would have that
stupid student loan paid off before the
business is closed today I'd be done
yeah and then I would take your fabulous
income go about your fabulous income and
get about the business of building
wealth cuz if you got nothing hanging
over your head you don't have a knife
hanging over the top of your head on a
thread that's bare you don't have any
risk it's gonna change the way you look
at each other also she brought the
student loans into your brand-new baby
tiny little naive little marriage and
it's sweet but it's gonna affect things
but if it's gone it's in the rearview
mirror and it doesn't affect anything
and she doesn't feel guilty for weighing
you down and you don't have to try to
convince her that it's no big deal
because it is no big deal to you you're
a math guy but there's this thing of oh
he came in with no student loans and I
came in with $100,000 of student loans
and he's got 125 thousand dollars in
debt for richer for poorer in sickness
and health and all my worldly goods I
pledge to you these are the old marriage
vows write a check today and pay it off
clean up your life sir